[Music]
so we're coming down to the close of all
right questions the last question i have
i know we've been focusing on revelation
chapter 13 in terms of identifying the
satanic trinity but there is a word
there for god's people in fact the bible
says
in verse 8 of revelation 13 and all that
dwell upon the earth shall worship him
whose names are not written in the book
of life of the lamb slain from the
foundation
of the world all right and again we see
well where is it okay let me just leave
it at that now the question the question
is
what are ways we can keep our names in
the lamb's book of life and exhibit the
patience and faith of the saints
let me pray father as we come to the
conclusion continue to bless please with
simple truths administered by your
spirit in jesus name amen how do you
keep your name the book of life very
very simple
obedience to god of course disobedience
through the power of the spirit let's go
to exodus 32 we'll read verses 31-33 as
we answer that question exodus 32 31-33
in this chapter the israelites have made
a golden calf while it was made by aaron
and the church leaders all the people
worshipped the calf except the levites
of course and moses and joshua who are
up in the mountain
moses is angry but not as angry as god
god wants to wipe out the entire islamic
nation and begin anew with moses moses
intercedes on behalf of the israelites
in that sense he's functioning like
christ here's what moses says to god
exodus 32 from verse 31 and moses
returned unto the lord and said oh this
people have sinned the great sin and
have made the god of gold
yet now if thou will forgive this sin
but if not not me i pray thee out of thy
book which thou has written so moses
says listen if you destroy them take my
name out of the book of life that's the
book he's referring to take it out
listen to what god said to moses in
verse 33
and the lord said unto him whose ever
have sinned against me
him will i block out of my book the
question was how can i keep my in the
book of life by doing the opposite of
what gets it out what gets in hell is
sin what keeps it in is obedience
through christ and i have to say through
christ let's go to revelation chapter 3
and let's read verse 5.
revelation 3 verse 5 the message to
sardis
revelation chapter 3 verse 5 these are
the words of christ
himself and christ said he that
overcometh
the same shall be clothed with white
raiment and i will not blot out his name
out of the book of life notice how the
verse
he that overcometh overcometh one sin
his name will not be blotted out so the
question is how do i keep my name
continue to be faithful to christ
through obedience of faith
simple as that
amen continue to be
people to christ through the obedience
it must be faithful obedience obedience
based on the word of god you trust god's
word you trust him you do what he says
amen but god told noah to build an ark
it made no sense to him at a secular
level no one had seen reigns he obeyed
because god said it
when peter when christ told peter go
fishing again peter said look we've been
fishing all night luke chapter five but
at your word we'll go that's the
obedience of faith that keeps our name
in the book of life simple obedience to
god
and that includes this sabbath if the
knowledge of it has come to you
if you're genuinely ignorant god is
merciful
but to be genuinely ignorant you must be
able to say to god i did not know and i
had no way of knowing those two elements
must be present or you cannot claim
ignorance
amen amen
you